hello and welcome to the why the first
episode with this epic new setup look
how clean this mirror is now let's go
watch memes where half of them is about
how unclean my mirror is do not buy
merch here only from represent help me
inform felix about this off-brand merch
that pops up above the real one what you
have to go to represent calm slash
PewDiePie that's the only place I sell
merch ok does that show up if you search
know represent shows up first
Wow PT Pike climb stick wow that's so
cool red bubble it's like the big one
that just blatantly rips off everyone
like the quality is so bad on these
prints like you might think you save
money by buying these but they look
absolutely unwearable i bought one thing
from here once and i immediately threw
it in the trash because it was just so
bad now moving on we should make Marcia
watch Riccardo Melo's with eye tracker 9
euro fine I just need to trick her it
needs to be genuine right I need to be
like hey might yeah what that's not my
voice hey hey might say come over here
and she'll come over here and then I
won't even tell her about the eye
tracker that's the only way to test if
my future wife is gay instead of mr.
beast planting 20 million treats each
one of us subs should plant one tree I
like that maybe we should do like a
charity stream for trees or some
I'm so giving maybe we should give us
charity for some trees or some machines
that'd be cool though I like that a they
a good idea top common decides my next
upload Mary Han performs Papa glory at
resurrection ritual it can't be done
there's a forbidden curse on Papa Gloria
she will never come back stop stop
crying I've seen this is amazing did
Brad cut this out I've reacted to this
before Brad cut this out oh my god mr.
B's is one of those rare youtubers that
you think is click baiting but actually
everything in the title says happened in
the video incredible what did this one
say I have a Lego car pity pie logic
watch memes while standing up play VR
will sit shut your freaking pie peep why
is this better
it's this better are you enjoying it
more now is it more entertaining now in
the VR game you are sitting down so of
course I'm gonna sit down when you
disable your comments you know you're
disabled you're defeated
I haven't even watched it yeah I didn't
watch the whole Betty out you know it's
just gonna be some eat incoherence apple
fortnight losing popularity minecraft
back to trending tuber simulator still
relevant goddamnit if you haven't
checked out tuber simulate through yet
you are missing out right now there's a
pirate versus ninja event check it out
let's check out some rooms I can't
record my display so we're doing it like
this you can't see it but damn so this
is the winner mug tuber look amazing
it's so crazy how creative people
marry ham Gloria Borger hamburger I like
it first time I like the hamburger
hamburger hey look I've seen this meme
can we bring back happiness and joy to
Brad please is there anything we can do
to bring him out of the darkness spoiled
child ranch dr. Phil for meme review
please we need to make it happen so
which youtubers should be sponsor next
mr. piece no one be all mine
sharing is caring fine then I recommend
PewDiePie
Thank You mr. piece very cool look
forward to the sponge nine-year-olds um
what you got there corpse of Gloria
Borger a smooth heat I like her this
meme has made it back for some reason
pity pie bread 1 & 2 come on memes made
by nine year olds that's probably true
when you thought you ran over an animal
but he was just marry him hey why does
everyone hate Mary heme she's the
greatest you just ran over
stop running over Mary Ellen it whoa a
linen he hits out at twitch after being
bad for and accidentally showing prawn
nine-year-olds incredible job
looks like twitch staff isn't a bunch of
hypocrite angels incredible it's time to
go
we'll say good news reporter I'm not
supposed to give my opinion but you were
the best popular is that Alright how
many times do I gotta say this remember
when Saitama met the Hulk and gave him a
Teddy twister until green breasts
milking now hold on just a second here
I'm not entirely convinced this happen
me explaining how Mary Han murdered Papa
Gloria my parents the police guys stop
believing in conspiracies okay you're
crazy
there's no way that happened even musk
writing a letter dear
that's a good me who is Papa Gloria and
why do I keep getting death threats from
strangers see this is a fake tweet this
confused me I was like actually worried
that this happened but what she actually
tweeted is this is not a real tweet for
me I know exactly why people are
tweeting me about public Gloria and
though I am more dangerous than I look
and occasionally foolishly
underestimated I'm not bad dangerous
it's the first time I've seen any one of
them acknowledge it that's amazing
Papa Gloria rest in peace hey sis came
so oh my god that is the best thing I've
ever seen in my life
six-six that's the devil number mr. Bies
had overtaken the poor brother small
town mr. beast you deserve it my big
bros homework 2010 minus 23 equals
impossible moussaka I have several
questions is this a real picture is that
a real picture
ha ha ha see if I use his light mode
there's an upward meme see he lives-- at
and uses Instagram for more than half of
his videos making when you get banned on
PDP submissions so you post your meme to
dank memes knowing it will eventually
end up on PDP submissions you know I'm
something of a genius got damn well
played unbanned that man you what you
want this god damn this is heavy
Mary hemmed in Korea bogus glory is dead
and my Rehan had nothing to do with it
so what if she's the one that had the
gun mr. beast 24 hours in the most
haunted place on earth
morgues right now boots could have won
the war easily but chose to be maturing
into me and that's a fact
yeah looking back it's like it is
obviously a big achievement to be the
first channeled a 200 million and I
definitely know we could have done it so
looking at it from that perspective is
like but it what's the right thing to do
Captain Marvel can
Thor's hammer according to brie Larson
now I don't think she did she actually
say that will you press the button you
get in the white you can't accept you
can't afford Photoshop I see this as an
absolute winner
that is a beautiful photo in pain that
the muscles on Hulk looks absolutely
perfect
what about Thor offworld Captain Marvel
unavailable puffer Gloria thank you like
right but big Aria now stop crying she's
dead
get over it move on with your life I
don't get it I don't play Minecraft I'm
not a nerd okay fine I'll play Minecraft
when there are 1.5 million people on the
subreddit when you're a meme doesn't get
1.5 million upload math is mad this is
people literally telling me that's what
you sound like a dying fart
I didn't spend seven minutes in
Photoshop for this not to get in front
page here's in 2019 boots in shut up oh
my god he actually did it anything you
can carry I'll pay for challenge
anything you carry I'll buy it challenge
oh my God look at all those mid rolls
see I don't say when no one likes Mary
she's like the best he's my favorite I
love Mary Ann only nineteen million nine
hundred nine
ninety-eight trees left to be planned
that I planted an apple tree good job my
mom typing are on Google represent calm
slice PewDiePie where you can check out
the epic merge epic merge if we don't
get Pierce to 100 million before August
first we won't be able to see the exact
moment he gets there because of
YouTube's oh my god hurry up and
subscribing I forgot hahaha I understand
that they had to add the update I kind
of get it you going to celebrate Peter
pie when he hits 100 mill no no I don't
think we'll see come on guys
right I can edit a Marvel movie if they
give me enough time Marvel movie haha
gotta come join us poppy
Oh Bobby goes to have bad Mary have you
guys always act like you're better than
me
oopsie guilty so longest handling three
to four days come on stop painting on my
girl why does mortgage look like
resident evil with facial animations on
500%
oh my cup launch bugs mom
popping oh yeah thanks for that to go
deep undercover to expose me Mary
hey what what you never played super
simulator you know it's fun right I'm
not supposed to give my opinion but give
it a try and then you can tell me if
it's
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]